oh yeah this movie's got some
[ __ ] science the Martian so the
Martian is directed by Ridley Scott
stars Matt Damon who plays astronaut
Mark Watney mark Watney was part of a
crew of astronauts who were on Mars and
his storm rosen's they have to cut their
visit short they're evacuating and upon
evacuating some debris it's mark Watney
and kills him so the crew has to leave
Mars without their fallen comrade they
had to leave him in his body behind only
thing mark Watney is still alive he
didn't die so now mark Watney is
stranded on Mars on a planet where
nothing is living nothing is growing he
has to survive long enough for the good
people of Earth the good people who
don't even know he's alive to come
rescue him this is kind of an update on
the whole men versus nature thing his
man versus nature on Mars directed by
Ridley Scott starring Matt Damon this
movie is castaway meets Apollo 13 and I
haven't seen any reviews for this movie
because I wanted to go into this movie
cult I read the book I loved it and I
just wanted to watch this movie it as of
right now I can promise you this there
are at least 50 reviews out there that
all call this movie castaway meets
Apollo 13 because there is no more
perfect way to describe this movie than
calling it castaway meets Apollo 13
first of all I love the character mark
Watney I thought Matt Damon played him
perfectly he's this really likable smart
guy who's in this shitty situation where
he's like I'm going to die here and at a
point he's like you know I'm not gonna
die here he just gets to work and you
start sciencing this [ __ ] out of the
situation to survive will the [ __ ]
science this is one of those movies
right when Mark Watney wakes up
generally speaking is kind of our intro
to his character you're looking at
you're like Matt Damon is a really good
actor and he's gonna show it in this
movie not only that but Ridley Scott has
made Mars cool he just made it look
interesting as well I mean it's a pretty
desolate looking place for all intents
and purposes he's in the middle of a
desert for the entire movie so you need
a director to bring life into this
desolate wasteland and Ridley Scott's
like hey I'll do it and I kind of seen
that movies lately a lot of times
directors like their movies get bigger
and bigger and bigger and you're like
something's missing and then they go
back to this really small movie you can
tell this movie certainly as a budget
but it's a movie about a guy trying to
survive it's very personal and that's
where directors are finding their
strength now but I love the supporting
cast also it goes from Mars and it goes
back to Earth and NASA and they're just
trying to bring this guy back Chiwetel
Ejiofor is one of the best actors
working right now we all knew that you
know why because we all saw serenity
we all knew that I also love the crew
he's he marked Wotton you have to see
that he has a relationship with the crew
that you really never see him interact
with this movie pulled that off very
very well probably the hardest part to
pull off in this movie they did it and
this movie is really humorous also
surprisingly so it could have been this
really drab downer of a movie it's
really easy to make a movie where a guy
is fighting the odds and he's trying to
stay alive really depressing the
director the writers the actor the
character they all work together to
translate this humor to you or you're
like I'm this not really as depressing
as it should be you see the margins
really about life and the fight to
survive the human spirit people coming
together to save another person that's
right the Martians like the essence of
Mortal Kombat is not about death but
life and in the world we live in today
where we see a lot of shitty things
happen on the news it's good to see a
movie fictional or not where people come
together to just save someone just very
simply put it's about human life in the
fight to save it it was really inspiring
movie guys to me this movie had really
everything I really wanted it to have a
great director great Direction great
cinematography a great character played
by a great actor great writing great
execution great suspense and most
importantly in a situation like this
great [ __ ] science this is one
of my favorites of the year I'm glad it
did not disappoint me because the
Martian is awesome tacular
right guys so the Martian have you seen
it what did you think about it every
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more